I think that the obama-clinton ticket
has been a fanciful dream of Democrats
for months and I always say I think it's
unlikely there is no chance we're going
to see an Obama Clinton tick in the
sense of obama wins the nomination
there's no chance he will pick Hillary
Rodham Clinton as VP reverse that if
Hillary Rodham Clinton wins the
nomination I acknowledge that there's
some chance she picks Barack Obama's VP
simply because Obama has evidence such a
clear ability to not only galvanized
youth but also on I think transcend
classic 1956 TS divides that haunt
Clinton and have haunted the Democratic
Party for some decades cultural divides
I speak of he also is a captivating
speaker especially large crowds and
that's pretty much what you want in an
army I say that it's unlikely still even
if Hillary Rodham Clinton is an army
because I go back to why I think most
vice presidents are selected I simply
don't think Barack compensates enough
for her weaknesses which are experience
which our national security still and
and I don't think that he certainly
doesn't bring a state to her illinois's
is firmly Democratic so Illinois won't
shift based on just elected Barack Obama
so I would say it's unlikely she picks
Barack but possible because of how
successful and really dramatic and
historic his campaign improving a bit
you